[Musique]
l'éditeur
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
au sénat
et cette semaine avec catalyseur notre
invité est la députée marie le bec
bonjour bonjour et c'est katia qui va
vous présenter bonjour marie levêque
vous êtes des puces et la république en
marge des yvelines première
vice-présidente du groupe la république
en marche l'assemblée alors vous êtes
une macro nist de la première heure vous
avez commencé à militer à droite mais
des jeunes pop de l'ump vous passez en
2015 aux jeunes avec macron vous êtes
d'ailleurs la benjamine des députés élus
dans le nouveau groupe dont vous vous
imposez rapidement comme l'un des
piliers toujours prête à monter au
créneau pour défendre la politique d'
emmanuel macron face aux attaques
marie le bec quand vous voyez la
virulence de certaines de ces attaques
est-ce que vous avez parfois un peu le
blues non je vois le blues du tout je
trouve que c'est un milieu dans lequel
s'est enfin la politique c'est un sujet
de passion donc c'est un milieu dans
lequel on vit sa passion aussi on ne
défend avec beaucoup de conviction ce en
quoi on croit les sujets que l'on veut
porter et donc je crois que la virulence
même si parfois elle peut être un peu
désagréable elle fait aussi partie du
débat politique
il faut dire que en dehors des moments
de débats et des changes les relations
entre tous les groupes parlementaires
sont bonnes et apaisée qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ceux qui vous disent que
vous êtes un peu trop exécutants de la
politique du gouvernement
non je crois qu'on a on a beaucoup
évolué bien la façon d'appréhender notre
mandat on avait beaucoup de primo
entrants politique dirons nous et donc
on a aussi appris cette relation entre
l'exécutif et la majorité et je crois
qu'on a su incarner un certain nombre de
batailles au sein au sein de
du parlement et puis on a traversé aussi
ensemble des crises qui a renforcé le
lien entre l'exécutif et la majorité et
puis parfois il faut admettre qu'on est
peut-être un peu plus dans un temps
exécutif comme la non cadre de cette
crise sanitaire et que peut-être le
parlement s'efface un petit peu devant
la prééminence de l'exécutif mais
l'important c'est cette balance qu'on
arrive en avait parfois le plus de
débats dans les groupes la majorité plus
partagés qu'est ce que vous vous dites
vous réjouissez de ça est ce que ça
montre que vous êtes un petit peu moins
au garde-à-vous un petit peu moins
godillots comme on a pu le dire un
certain moment moi ça fait presque deux
ans que je bureaux du groupe est
notamment vice présidente de ce groupe
je vais vous dire que jamais le groupe
n'a été au garde à vous il ya toujours
eu des débats des débats entre nous en
interne et je pense que c'est important
c'est aussi ce qui fait notre identité
on a su aussi choisir les combats sur
lesquelles on voulait vraiment quitté
ses valises et sur un peu sur la crise
qu vide mais je crois que c'est un temps
exécutif et c'est légitime que le
parlement fasse on a su être au
rendez-vous comme c'était nécessaire
quand il a fallu voter des projets de
loi de finances rectificative pour venir
souvent de faire des mesures de soutien
pour nos entreprises mais aussi pour des
particuliers
donc on sait être être là mais il faut
accepter aussi que cette crise elle ne
peut pas être géré par 500 députés mais
qu'elle doit être
il doit y avoir un cadre très clair qui
peut être que fixée par l'exécutif réel
et tout de suite on va dérouler les
titres de cette émission
oui avec des restrictions appliquées
dans trois départements supplémentaires
le gouvernement prépare l'opinion un
durcissement emmanuel macron annonce de
nouvelles mesures à prendre dans les
prochains jours et semaines
on reverra la semaine vue du parlement
le sait
adopté en deuxième lecture la
proposition de loi danic billon sur les
crimes sexuels sur mineur avec un
changement de taille par rapport à la
première version le seuil d'âge
désormais fixé à 15 ans et puis on
parlera du projet de loi de lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique qui arrive à
l'assemblée en séance publique le 29
mars
les oppositions promettent de livrer
bataille contre le texte
l'un des derniers grands projets de loi
du quinquennat et on commence avec le
suivi de la pandémie par l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et semaine toujours difficile pour le
gouvernement contraint d'annoncer de
nouvelles restrictions tout en laissant
les écoles ouvertes
le gouvernement défend désormais aussi
les centres de vaccination récit d'une
semaine d'hésitations et de décisions
vue du parlement avec elsa mandingue
havas confinement attestation
vaccination les oppositions n'ont pas
manqué de critiquer l'exécutif sur sa
gestion de la crise sanitaire
finalement après un confinement à
déconfinement art confinement à rodez
confinement un couvre-feu de 9h à
couvrot a dit à deux lutteurs ne vois là
va confier confinement territoriale
partiellement des confiné et un
couvre-feu à 19 heures avec attestation
sortie mais finalement semble finalement
6 alors le gouvernement tente de
préciser sa stratégie en annonçant tout
d'abord la montée en puissance de la
vaccination avec la création notamment
de 35 vaccinodromes dans les tout
prochains jours n'a jamais eu de
religion anti vaccinaux dreux le
principe c'était celui de ne pas
sacrifier la proximité sur l'autel de
l'efficacité
nous sommes bientôt à 1500 centres sur
tout le territoire national permettant
aux personnes de faire un minimum de
trajet pour pouvoir être vacciné et
parce que les livraisons vont augmenter
massivement à partir de dans dix jours
eh bien nous allons en plus de cela
déployer des grands centres de
vaccination capable de lachenaie
plusieurs milliers de personnes par jour
il y à aussi l'épineuse question de
l'ouverture des écoles ou les cas se
multiplient
le ministre de l'éducation nationale est
revenu sur la non du président de la
république
l'accès à la vaccination pour les
professeurs dans le courant du mois
d'avril
il était normal d'aller des personnes
les plus vulnérables
jusqu aux personnes les moins
vulnérables fort heureusement jusqu'à
présent les professeurs sont dans les
catégories les moins contaminés il est
normal maintenant que leur tour arrive
mais le gouvernement prévient les
prochaines semaines seront dures devant
les sénateurs le premier ministre
n'exclut pas des mesures supplémentaires
nous sommes face à une troisième vague
particulièrement virulente qui nous
conduit à prendre des mesures
territorialisée et de freinage est plus
adapté possible mais oui monsieur le
sénateur que nous pourrions être
conduits à durcir
en fonction de l'évolution de la
pandémie un gouvernement pris entre la
crainte de prochains jours qui
s'annoncent très difficiles et l'espoir
d'une sortie de crise avec la
vaccination alors marie le dec
emmanuel macron justifie sa décision de
ne pas avoir décidé de confinement en
janvier et pour autant il annonce de
nouvelles mesures à prendre dans les
prochains jours les prochaines semaines
on a du mal à vraiment comprendre ce que
cela veut dire
est ce que ce n'est pas quelque part un
aveu d'échec non je crois pas que ce
soit un aveu d'échec parce que on a
jusqu'à présent réussi à contenir la
progression du virus et la circulation
du virus sur notre territoire dans des
niveaux qui pour nos services de santé
était acceptable
il y avait une pression c'est indéniable
mais c'était acceptable et ça permettait
de maintenir au maximum une vie presque
normale
vos enfants pouvaient aller à l'école
vous pouviez vous rendre sur votre lieu
de travail selon a beaucoup parlé après
le premier confinement et quand on a
fait le deuxième confinement en novembre
de l'acceptabilité c'était dur de faire
du télétravail toute la semaine chez soi
c'était dur d'avoir ses enfants chez soi
à l'occasion du pont de liberté on a
pendant ces deux mois que nous avons
gagné pu maintenir une activité presque
normal une vie presque normale vous
entendez un beaucoup de médecins et des
membres de l'opposition qui critique
aussi ce qu'il qualifie désormais de
paris des manuels macro ce pari qui a
consisté à confiner le plus tard
possible mais c'est très bien d'une je
crois qu'il faut arrêter avec ce terme
de paris c'est pas un pari c'est des
choix de politique publique que l'on
fait s'il était en responsabilité il
n'aurait probablement pas pris les mêmes
et on ne parie pas avec la vie des gens
on est en train de faire des choix on a
un certain nombre de paramètres qui nous
sont présentés par les acteurs de santé
par les acteurs économiques et il faut
qu'on décide sur la base de ces
paramètres et moi je ne crois pas qu'on
se soit trompé il faut arrêter de croire
que un confinement ça n'a pas de
conséquence sociale le conséquences
psychologiques de conséquences
économiques
tout cela a un coût c'est un non humains
ce à un coût économique c'est indéniable
donc chaque jour gagné est une victoire
aujourd'hui on est dans une accélération
du virus c'est indéniable et on prend
des mesures en fonction de la situation
donc vous justifier ce côté on est
obligé de prendre une mesure peut-être
une autre parce qu'il ya un côté
imprévisible dans la progression ce
virus était tous ces nombreux variant
est ce que vous reconnaissez une
certaine impuissance public finalement
gouvernement face à ce virus d'un
nouveau type nouveau genre cette
clinique genre oui on est malgré tout
confrontée à une crise d'une ampleur
inédite à une crise qui nous a aussi
imposé de regarder notre la façon dont
était bâti notre système de souveraineté
que ce soit en matière de masse que ce
soit en matière de vaccins est ce que je
constate c'est que aujourd'hui les
efforts de la part de nos chercheurs les
efforts de la part de nos entreprises
les efforts de la part de nos capacités
industrielles les efforts de la part de
notre corps enseignant de notre corps
médical font que on arrive de plus en
plus à s'adapter
je crois qu'il faut saluer aussi savait
s'adapter c'est pas si facile changer
ses process c'est pas si facile et il
faut saluer la capacité d'adaptation
pour deux et dans la logistique dans
l'organisation de l'état qu'on a pu
souligner et bien au certains parlent de
cette lourdeur mais moi ce que je
constate quand je vais sur le terrain
toutes les semaines on a un échange avec
le préfet avec les acteurs économiques
vous savez quand je vais voir une
entreprise et qu'elle me dit et ben moi
j'avais des difficultés en quinze jours
j'ai pu avoir un financement
et ben moi je trouve que on a bien sûr
toujours d où dort mais on a aussi su
faire preuve d'une très grande
réactivité
alors il ya un vrai sujet de
préoccupation aujourd'hui ce sont là les
écoles qu'est ce que vous proposez pour
pouvoir continuer à les garder ouvertes
celles du gouvernement
il faut bien renforcé les protocoles
sanitaires aujourd'hui alors il y a dans
les écoles de 20 on est en capacité
aujourd'hui de plus en plus contrôler la
la situation l'épidémie accès dans les
écoles comme elle accélère dans la
société il n'y a pas de raison qu'il ya
un décalage particulier mais on sait
faire des protocoles on sait isoler une
classe quand il ya un début de kloster
on sait fermer un établissement si c'est
nécessaire et c'est toujours mieux que
de fermer l'intégralité des écoles à
dire une entreprise on va plus pouvoir
du tout mangé avec nos collègues blessés
des jeunes l'école mais c'est certain
que j'ai la peau la plupart des avants
de chirurgie eu un échange avec des
enseignants de ma circonscription il
jusqu'à présent les enfants manger en
quinconce les lycéens qui sont peut-être
la population qui se contaminent le plus
entre ils sont 2000 jauge est
aujourd'hui par exemple dans des écoles
primaires où il faut maintenir la
cantine parce que c'est impossible pour
les parents de devoir faire des
allers-retours et récupérer leurs
enfants
les enfants ont des places attitrées
toujours en face d'eux mêmes personnes
parce que ce qui est important aussi
quand vous avez un enfant qui est testé
positif c'est de pouvoir tracer un peu
près les cas contacts et donc il y a un
gros effort qui est fait et il faut
quand même saluer les primaires les
collégiens les lycéens quand ils sont en
présentiel
il respecte le port du masque la
solution c'est quoi c'est le
renforcement des protocoles sanitaires
et la vaccination
la vaccination si comme pour grand alors
la vaccination de l'union elle va
démarrer à partir de mi-avril fin avril
on espère le plus rapidement possible et
puis la vaccination combiner un
renforcement des mesures combinées à
l'arrivée des vacances de pâques va
permettre je l'espère de freiner cette
cette épidémie dans les écoles mais
d'une il n'y a rien d'anormal à ce qu'il
y ait plus de cas vu que le virus
s'accélère dans la société et de deux
mois je crois que il faut collectivement
que l'on bataille le plus possible pour
garder le plus longtemps possible les
écolos vert si jamais il devait y avoir
une fermeture il ne faut pas que ce soit
un tabou et ça fait partie des
discussions que l'exécutif peut avoir
mais je crois que impérativement il faut
qu'on se bat ensemble pour garder les
écoles ouvertes alors on va passer au
deuxième thème de cette émission le
retour d'une proposition de loi qui
était sous les feux de l'actualité la
proposition de loi billon au sénat on en
parle tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le parlement a mis le turbo sur ce texte
qui entend mieux lutter contre les
crimes sexuels sur mineurs la
proposition de loi a été largement
modifié à l'assemblée seuil d'âge fixée
à 15 ans 18 ans en cas d'inceste jeudi
le sénat a largement approuvé cette
nouvelle version et apporter des
modifications assez marginal cécile 6e
sa loi a été largement modifié par les
députés mais pour la sénatrice annie
guillon peu importe l'assemblée
nationale a poursuivi le même objectif
qu'elle protéger les mineurs des crimes
sexuels ce texte apporte des avancées
majeures est attendu car il entérine un
virage décisif dans la manière
d'appréhender les violences sexuelles
sur mineures à présent un enfant ne sera
plus jamais considéré comme complice ou
complaisant vis-à-vis des actes sexuels
qu'un adulte comme est sur lui
seuil de non consentement à 15 ans au
lieu de 13 ans définition d'un viol
incestueux allongement des délais de
prescription des viols sur mineure
l'assemblée nationale a ajouté beaucoup
de mesures qui avait été proposé par les
sénateurs socialistes en première
lecture
la sénatrice marie pierre de la gontrie
regrettent qu'elle ait été refusée à ce
moment là le 21 janvier nous avons
proposé le seuil d'âge à 15 ans rejeté
nous avons proposé l'inceste interdit à
18 ans rejeté
il a donc fallu que les semaines passent
pour que au final chacun se rende à la
raison et décide de soutenir les
propositions qui furent les nôtres
opposé en première lecture à la mesure
principale de cette loi le seuil de non
consentement le garde des sceaux a salué
un texte historique
le texte qui vous est présenté porte
aujourd'hui des avancées inédite
l'ambition historique qu'il porte nous
permettra de dire solennellement aux
victimes il y aura un avant et un après
cette loi le texte reviendra pour une
seconde lecture à l'assemblée nationale
le 15 avril prochain
marie lebey car il n'y a plus de débat
autour du seuil d'âge à 15 ans à parler
d'un sujet qui fâche
en revanche un petit peu plus
aujourd'hui les associations sont
opposés à la clause appelée de façon
assez romantique la clause romeo et jeu
yet qui permet les relations entre un
mineur et un jeune majeur s'il ya un
écart d'âge de moins de cinq ans est ce
que vous comprenez l'émoi des
associations aujourd'hui je crois que je
vais reprendre ce qui a été dit par le
garde des sceaux sur sur sur ce sujet on
est dans une société où effectivement
parfois il y a des relations entre un
très jeune majeur je crois que c'est
important de préciser ce terme est un
mineur ça peut arriver à 18 ans quand
vous êtes au lycée il peut y avoir un
jeune de 18 ans est une jeune lycéenne
de 15 ans ou inversement d'ailleurs et
donc je crois que c'est aussi la prise
en compte de la réalité de notre société
avec une maturité sexuelle qui peut
évoluer et je crois que tous les mets ça
car c'est quand même un trou dans la
raquette et que ça peut protéger un
jeune majeur qui commettent des
agressions aussi donc non mais je crois
que honnêtement aujourd'hui tous les
tous les garde-fous sont mis en place
mais ça permet aussi d'avoir une forme
de discernement quant à des situations
un peu particulière où effectivement
vous fréquentez notamment quand vous
êtes on va dire presque un jeune adulte
entre 16 et 22 ans vous fréquentez des
majeures des mineurs et parfois il se
peut que vous ayez des relations et donc
je pense que c'était une disposition qui
est nécessaire et qui permet de prendre
en compte encore une fois la réalité de
la situation
donc voilà je crois encore une fois
qu'un un juge sera faire la part des
choses entre une relation amoureuse
consentie en train un jeune un mineur et
un majeur est quelque chose qui
relèverait du viol ou du caractère un
sonar juste évident c'est justement
puisque le texte crée de nouvelles
infractions l'agression sexuelle
incestueuse et le viol incestueux et ce
qu'il y a eu pour vous quand même
suffisamment de recul de travail sur ce
sujet est ce que le législateur n'agit
pas un peu sous le coup de l'émotion
après
le livre de camille kouchner familia
grande et est ce que il ya eu assez de
recul pour moi je crois qu'on a eu
effectivement avec familia grande d où
ou d'autres d'ailleurs
je pense que cette prime aura qui a
sorti son livre le consentement je crois
qu'on vit ces sujets sur le dossier
depuis le début du mandat on a une forme
de libération de la parole sur un
certain nombre de sujets notamment cette
question de l'inceste et je crois que
effectivement depuis longtemps on sait
que c'est un sujet qui existe en france
et pour lequel on n'a pas totalement les
outils juridiques nécessaires pour
accompagner les mineurs et ensuite quand
ils deviennent majeurs pour la
libération de la parole et la prise en
charge
finalement de la plante qui peut être
déposée ce que je trouve très
intéressant avec ce texte c'est que
finalement oui c'est un texte pour
lequel on va vite mais c'est aussi la
prise en compte de cette nécessaire
évolution de notre système judiciaire
vaut mieux protéger les victimes
mais juste avant est ce que ça se crée
ce que ça va assez loin parce que par
exemple sur le cas de l'un s'atteler
frères soeurs oncles et tantes sont pas
pris en compte dans les infractions
est ce que c'est normal est-ce qu'on
peut estimer qu'il n'y a pas ce que
lorsqu'il s'agit vraiment des ascendants
des parents des grands parents ce qui
n'aurait pas fallu élargir le spectre
moi je crois qu'on a en tout cas dans un
premier temps créer de nouveaux outils
et ça ne change pas les outils et qui
existait par par le passé vous pouvez
constance aggravante mais vous pouvez
toujours être être condamné
effectivement si vous êtes dans une
relation incestueuse avec votre oncle
votre votre votre tante et donc je pense
que c'est on a créé et surtout des
nouveaux outils qui permettent de
répondre à ce à quoi on ne pouvait pas
répondre avant je pense par exemple à la
prescription qui est repoussée s'il ya
un autre crime qui est commis et qui
permet je crois que ce qui était
important c'était une fois que vous avez
la libération la parole qu'on a vu au
cours du quinquennat et ensuite la
capacité à prendre en charge
correctement et jusqu'à présent on
n'avait pas les outils qui était
parfaitement adapté on a su adapter
notre réponse jusqu'à attache-moi que
c'est très important de la loi peut
changer les mentalités donc pour vous la
loi peut changer les mentalités et là on
voit c'est aussi la société qui fait
bouger la loi très fortement parce que
il ya tout d'un coup une forme de rêve
c'était presque un peu oppressante parce
qu'on avait toutes ces histoires qui
remonté et elles ont du bon parce
qu'elle permet de prendre en compte ces
cas une toute dernière question sur eric
dupond-moretti comme avocat il a plaidé
notamment l'inceste consentis dans une
affaire à amiens jugé en 2012
il est attaqué pour cela par des
personnalités par exemple comme
christine angot est ce que pour vous ce
passé d'avocat c'est un handicap comme
garde des sceaux
moi je bon je sens m'exprimer sur cette
affaire oui je ne connais pas et donc je
ne maîtrise pas tous les noms mais je
crois qu'il ya même certaines
personnalités
oui mais je crois que encore une fois je
veux dire quand on arrive en politique
quand notamment quand on est garde des
sceaux ministre
on incarne aussi un certain nombre de
combats et on les vit par rapport à son
passé elles sont vécues et c'est aussi
ce qui fait sa capacité finalement être
un ministre qui dans l'action qui agit
et qui prend en main qui choisit un
certain nombre de combats moi ce que je
constate c'est que aujourd'hui le garde
des sceaux a permis aussi en partenariat
avec le parlement les deux chambres
d'ailleurs je crois qu'il faut le
souligner qui était qui ont travaillé en
train de faire une fois n'est pas
coutume de faire évoluer la loi et de
prendre en compte la parole des victimes
encore une fois je crois qu'il faut
saluer le fait de dire finalement on a
depuis le début du mandat
une prise en charge une meilleure
compréhension de mes reconnaissances de
question des violences sexuelles et
sexistes et qu'on avance progressivement
au fur et à mesure des textes et
qu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'on a un beau
texte que l'on doit saluer et qui encore
une fois permet de vraiment prendre en
compte ce qu'est l'inceste dans notre
société
allez on va terminer avec le projet de
loi climat qui sera débattu la semaine
prochaine dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée
[Musique]
et c'est le dernier grand texte du
quinquennat il arrive en séance à
l'assemblée
lundi plus de sept mille amendements une
grande pile ont été déposés bataille
annoncée donc dans l'hémicycle puisque
le texte continue de diviser sur tous
les bancs et notamment à l'assemblée
emmanuel va marc wargon pardon qui a été
attaqué par le député de la france
insoumise loïc prud'hommes a dû défendre
les ambitions de ce texte on écoute la
loi climat et résilience que vous portez
affiche de bien modeste objectif vous y
défendent est encore une économie
dirigée par la main invisible du marché
qui nous vend une surconsommation
mortifère pour nos ressources et le
climat je prétend au contraire qu'il
faut rentrer dans l'ère de la sobriété
depuis 2010 est cette majorité plus que
d'autres à engager les transformations
écologiques indispensable à la
transition écologique à laquelle nous
devons faire face
cette loi elle a été évaluée par un
cabinet indépendant montre que nous
saurons atteindre la stratégie nationale
bas carbone
qui d'autre que nous la fait
l'instauration du dédit déco side
le malus au point des véhicules
l'interdiction de louer 1,8 million de
logements locatifs passoires thermiques
l'obligation de diviser par 2
l'artificialisation des sols la création
d'un carbone score la généralisation de
l'éducation à l'environnement la
réduction des vols domestiques pour
favoriser le train la transition
écologique a commencé elle se déroule
dans ce pays nous atteindrons nos
objectifs
alors marie lebey que vous étiez en
commission du matin au soir vous avez
fait dans le détail ce texte
la responsable du groupe la public en
marche sur ce projet de loi les
oppositions de droite comme de gauche
font entendre leur mécontentement et
certains vous reprochent notamment de ne
faire passer aucun de leurs amendements
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez est-ce
que vous pensez que lors du débat en
séance
il y aura des amendements de
l'opposition qui pourront être acceptés
alors japon à paris aucun moment parce
qu'il ya eu plus de 400 âmes
et qui ont été adoptées ensuite
effectivement j'entends la france
soumise dans votre extrait qui fait son
show mais je regrette qu'on n'ait pas vu
davantage la france sera soumise en
commission plutôt que faire son show au
moment des questions au gouvernement
et puis bien sûr la commission permet
souvent un travail de fond qui permet
des avancées peut-être plus technique et
on a pu aussi identifier à travers ce
travail de commission les combats qu'on
souhaitait porter ensemble avec les
groupes d'opposition que soit le parti
socialiste les républicains il y en a un
certain nombre est donc généralement le
temps qui est dévolue entre la
commission et la science permet
finalement à tous les groupes
parlementaires de se mettre d'accord
pour arriver en séance et portait un
texte ensemble on va parler du fond
justement manger végétarien c'est l'une
des habitudes les plus efficaces pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
alors pourquoi la majorité tels
réticente à instaurer une option
végétarienne dans les cantines de façon
obligatoire
alors on n'est pas du tout opposée à
instaurer une options végétariennes on
attendait les résultats de
l'expérimentation de la loi agriculture
alimentation qui nous ont quittés nous
ont été présentés la dent dans l'antre
l'entreprise dont l'audience de la
commission et de la séance et qui
devrait permettre in fine et de proposer
effectivement une option hebdomadaire
végétarienne dans les menus scolaires
ensuite on a jamais eu d'obligation pour
vous pour les cantines ou est-ce qu'il
faut que ça arrête
il faut dire la vérification dans les
tales of war ou jeudi à savoir la
transformation de l'expérimentation
dégâts nîmes en obligations avec donc un
menu hebdomadaire végétariens et puis
ensuite il y aura cette expérimentation
porté à l'article 59 qui permettra de
faire notamment une options
végétariennes quotidienne dans certaines
cantines mais d'une il faut dire deux
choses
les collectivités sont très en avance
sur ce sujet beaucoup font déjà
davantage de bio davantage de local et
davantage de végétariens parce qu'elle
le souhaite parce que c'est une demande
aussi des familles et faut dire aux gens
tant que ça dépend des collectivités oui
mais dans les cantines il faut
reconnaître les enfants mangent de
manière très équilibrée parce qu'il ya
un an
les menus sont très encadrées et qu'il y
a une vraie concertation avec les
familles avec des diététiciennes et que
ça et puis ensuite je crois que il faut
dans l'article 59
on donne cette possibilité
d'expérimenter mais il faut prendre en
compte aussi que certaines collectivités
je pense notamment à celles qui font vie
dans les écoles primaires où il ya
souvent qu'un seul menu qui est proposé
elles n'ont pas forcément les moyens
d'avoir une double option et donc il
faut trouver les bons équilibres là
c'était l'article 59 sur le menu
végétarien parlons juste l'article 4 du
projet de loi qui vise à interdire les
publicités sur les énergies fossiles et
pour autant la publicité sur les
véhicules les plus polluants n'est pas
interdite
est ce que vous n'êtes pas allé jusqu'au
bout finalement est-ce que ça va servir
à quelque chose
d'interdire juste la publicité sur les
énergies fossiles
alors ça c'est un réclamer non malus
serait section alors cet article classe
il a fait je voulais la corde l'objet de
beaucoup de débats et même de débat en
interne ce qui prouvait les mains
d'enrichissant main qui pouvaient
ensuite cet article 4 il ne peut pas
être pris seul il doit être pris aussi
avec l'article 5 qui fixe un peu les
engagements volontaires que les filières
devront prendre en matière
d'amélioration de leurs messages
publicitaires et l'article 20 qui
permettra in fine et d'établir un écho
score est donc ce que les députés de la
majorité ont proposé et sur lequel
honnêtement on se retrouve avec les
oppositions d'ailleurs c'est le fait de
dire peut-être que il faut que les
causes corps soient présents dans les
publicités
ensuite il y à des secteurs pour
lesquels on peut avancer plus vite et on
pense notamment à la filière textile par
exemple
et puis ensuite je crois qu'il faut
saluer le travail car engagé la
rapporteure notamment sur renforcer les
dispositions contre ben moi j'ai vous
voulez pas pénaliser des certains
secteurs en fait vous faites attention à
ce que l'on croit et c'est je crois
notre identité vous voyez en matière
d'écologie c'est de dire il faut donner
égalité des éléments d'information aux
consommateurs et ensuite le consommateur
fera son arbitrage moi honnêtement je ne
suis pas du tout pour une société où
parce qu'un produit est mauvais on
interdirait la publicité pour désinciter
les gens à consommer crois que chacun
doit faire son arbitrage
et puis si on estime à mon qu'un produit
est vraiment néfaste pour la santé pour
l'environnement le législateur prend ses
responsabilités et l'interdît à la
commercialisation
mais je crois par la publicité qu'il
faille basse vraiment en quelques
secondes en parallèle le sénat commence
à préparer l'examen du projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui inscrit à la
sauvegarde de l'environnement à
l'article 1 de la constitution
est ce que vous comprenez la bataille
sémantique qui se joue en c'est garantir
du côté de la version de l'assemblée
agir pour l'instant du côté du sénat ça
du fonds où c'est que politique pour
vous non je crois que il ya
effectivement un enjeu majeur puisque ça
donnera finalement qu'elle ait
l'obligation de l'état pour la
préservation de l'environnement et le
passé par la sémantique et un degré
d'importance mais je crois que quand on
est sur des textes aussi fondamentaux
fin des des décisions sur notre
constitution qui soit aussi importante
c'est important qu'il y ait un dialogue
approfondi entre le sénat et l'assemblée
donc laissons le sénat débattre et
ensuite il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire qui permettra d'aboutir
j'espère un consensus très bien suivre à
sa merci beaucoup mais le fait d'avoir
été l'invité de parlement hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine guillaume
gontard président du groupe écologiste
au sénat sera avec nous ciao
[Musique]